eu acho que é uma coisa muito importante
em nossas vidas que estão na expectativa
é eventualmente pt
sobre o que eu vou falar é exercício
físico não é também chamado de ilusões
nem falar sobre o que é estranho não vai
falar sobre como fazer o cruzeiro quando
fazer quando fazer o que vai falar na
minha perspectiva e norte nós enquanto
pessoas
infelizmente quem tem ficado nem até
agora viu que é um símbolo questões que
são transversais e porque nessa
transversalidade há sempre um elemento
comum somos nós que somos as pessoas e
com algumas nuances e com falaram e com
o comitê fica aí - estamos aqui falar
sobre emissões não há dez emissões assim
com as exibições repetem em cada um de
nós
manifesta se eventualmente forma
diferente e eventualmente situações que
levam a que ela se manifesta em forma
diferente se tivesse ajuda
infelizmente a mariana e o domingo do
erro e já não estão cá poderia mandar um
ajuda com os live que eu acho que é o
salário inicial
vocês se algum de vocês nesta sala se
identifica com esta significa que está
se desertificando eventualmente punho no
ar porque às vezes nós olhamos para as
coisas e sim jimoh saque o que é óbvio
dou os parabéns porque você se casar
nunca se aperceberam já foram em alguma
altura da vossa vida o mais forte mais
rápido mais resiliente e quando olhamos
com aquela fotografia
vemos que valeu foi mais forte foi mais
resiliente e que ter um tipo mais forte
que todos os outros
estamos a falar de milhões quando
olhamos pra que o conseguimos perceber
que o bom início
alguém tomou a decisão por nós
naquele momento mas houve uma tomada de
decisão ea partir daí o caminho a
percorrer e que o caminho é percorrido
mais uma vez em um movimento que nós
estamos a falar aqui hoje
foi feito com companhia alguns percebem
como companhia evento aumentos como
competição
vê alguma forma todos tiveram que
percorrer uma determinada forma e muitas
vezes nós temos dificuldade em escolher
a forma como nós vamos caminhar o nosso
percurso a forma como nós caminhamos e
eventualmente nos transportamos do city
para o outro é vai fazer com que as
coisas se repitam ao longo do tempo
possa ter significância em determinado
momento ao sucesso não é quantificável
por um número mas sim porque uma tarefa
foi cumprida a tarefa da fundação ea
partir daí geras vida quando passamos
por outro está uma partida já estamos a
partilhar o seu que ainda não tinham
confiança aos 78 anos
vamos ver mais uma vez da república ao
início a uma partida que vai
acompanhando está ali por trás nos pés e
uma professora
há um caminho a percorrer do início até
o fim a uma meta a atingir
porque a minha finalização sempre que
chegar ao fim e não vencer
os separarem bem eu cheguei atrás do
primeiro
agora nós vamos perceber orientado para
o processo uma vez orientada para um
objetivo comum o foco seria chegar em
primeiro lugar e eventualmente aquilo
que é o objetivo do monte nós com o que
chegou em primeiro lugar naquela altura
estou a dizer é obrigado pela tua
chegada em primeiro lugar eu tive que
chegar em segundo
muitas vezes nós não temos este nível de
entendimento e partilham
os outros e quando nós começamos a
perceber e foi aqui o desafio lançar o
que é que nós vamos fazer de novo e de
diferente para 2016 o que o objetivo vai
pra mim o que eu quero passar e viver em
2016 porque que eventualmente não tinha
em 2015 em 2014
nalguns casos 9 já podemos falar em 20
30 ou 40 anos eventualmente mais quando
vocês olham pra que o fla é o que vem à
cabeça algo depende de um passado de
experiências e vivências e ensina mente
eventualmente aos olhos de outros e que
quer dizer outra coisa qualquer
completamente diferente
então mais uma vez nós estamos prontos
as projeções daquilo que nos é posto à
frente
gosto muito do sistema educativo também
trabalhe com os alunos nas escolas
felizmente alguém passou por aqui e
emissões e o conheço 11 no local
na minha escola os alunos em contexto de
sala de aula e fora
vou tentar andar a autonomia a uma
palavra que eu gosto muito me identifico
que é facilitador
então quando eu facilito uma
aprendizagem do alto linha mostra o que
é minha e eventualmente se você estiver
em um chute certo
amanhã vou pegar nessa facilitação e
transformar aquilo que foi tá em
conhecimento e vivência em ação
nada vai acontecer sem que eu tenha em
algum momento da minha vida
a dificuldade em sucesso
primeiras tentativas para aprender no
que o primeiro slide ninguém estava lá
para esse constrangimento pelo im de
sair pelo caminho ficam muito não é nem
todos o espermatozóide chegaram no
início até o fim
alguns têm que olhar o evento aumenta ao
longo da evolução do ser humano muito
coisa teve que ser alterada
mesmo assim cada um nós que aqui está
mais uma vez df já foi o que chegou em
primeiro lugar quando nós voltamos para
trás e eu gosto de olhar para isto como
um dos grandes vilões como é que os
nossos pais nos educaram quantas vezes é
que nós constrange em desenvolvimento
dos nossos filhos não corra não faças e
ainda por cima o motivo de punição e
fiscais ainda levas quando vou para a
escola porque escolas são fechadas e
eventualmente não estão preparadas
no entanto na altura das nossas vidas
não devia mais de movimento é via -
preparação para o movimento
hoje nós estamos a transmitir
verbalmente eventualmente não pelo
exemplo que atividade física exercício
físico é bom para nossa saúde pois
quando chegamos às escolas há cada vez
menos horas cada vez menos a um
propósito de abraçar e educar
quantas vezes é que nós vamos educando
as pessoas estão à nossa volta pra estar
inquieta aplicado estava aveiro os
títulos e eu lembrei de que sim é bom
nas escolas
a china se não vou trabalhar com o
computador
alguém aí sabe formatar um computador
nesta sala
no âmbito do exercício físico eu sou o
anormal no âmbito da informática que os
bichos também continue normal mas agora
faço uma pergunta quantos de nós é que
estava armado ice ou ensinar a gerir as
emissões identificarem suas negativas e
em vez de fazer de vítima
as pessoas as situações que nos
interessam encontrou nossas emissões
evento uma prática com paixão de
entendimento do governo é que o que nos
trouxe até aqui
eventualmente tentar tirar a cara por
ter só que eu não sou fundamentalista
temos que arranjar um equilíbrio em tudo
isto para conseguir viver no dia devia
nós temos que dar alguma forma conseguir
equilibrar as novas tecnologias e que o
que se calhar era o que nós vemos há uns
anos atrás
alguns de vocês estão habituados a esta
pirâmide numa pirâmide de um psicólogo
chamá-lo para mim é simples
independentes ainda tem validade
científica se não tem no entanto o
street fica aqui o que é essencial para
as nossas vidas
se vocês quiserem partilhar comigo
alguém está nesta sala muito muito muito
muito muito muito muito à vontade na
casa do im
muito muito mesmo
ninguém por não querer adivinhar se
alguém de repente tivesse uma
necessidade imensa de ir à casa de banho
o que fazer com que a casa vai sair
porque está na base das nossas
necessidades com seres humanos
as necessidades primárias e pós
apartheid em você está edificada a
seguir adiante cidade vende cidade
sentimos seguros
já falamos de segurança o que a família
eventualmente vai dar algumas
comunidades onde a segurança é um dos
pontos fundamentais
enquanto eu como escritor trem estão nas
aulas de grupo em primeiro lugar fazer
com que as pessoas sintam seguras
mostrados o que nem vamos fazer isso
existe
estou entregar segurança e autonomia
para poderem decidir não chama situação
sim eu não quero ninguém é exercitar de
forma o resultado porque eu quero fazer
alterações mudança mudanças de uso de
vida
nós temos que de alguma forma a
respeitar estas situações mesmo
exercício físico e atividade física
agora vamos entrar aqui um paradoxo que
fomos educados para a inatividade
estamos a ser educados para a
inatividade e de um dia pro outro
quando chegam os adultos a nossa russa
2016 e passa a ser ativo
achei esse mesmo é difícil sair de um
dia pro outro começar a integrar estas
coisas nossas vidas habitual é biológico
não deve ser eficiente fazerem mesmo
internet gastar menos energia possível
é por isso que nós temos a tendência em
termos de cheste peso nós temos de ter
somos bons em poupar é biológico havia
antigamente é que nos obrigava a gastar
energia para viver uns hoje precisamente
o contrário
por isso a ex de ansiedade em termos de
saúde também a parte física uma
perspectiva do bem estar enquanto
continuamos a subir
vemos que eu ia maio temos amor
conhecimento cidade básicas segurança
para os amigos reconhecimento e que
possamos entrar nas questões da
autoestima
nós precisamos de nos sentir bem de ser
reconhecido pelos nossos passos
as perceções a pressão nós temos né
a cultura do exercício físico
a gente tenta e significância
continuamos é que fomos educados que
realmente é importante nós tentamos a
nossa saúde fazia exercício físico
no entanto todos nós fomos ensinados
pelo menos durante uma década é 15 anos
teríamos que lavar os dentes por roupa
pra lavar as meias cuecas palava não foi
assim que os vossos pais de nossos pais
andavam atrás nós atrás de nós feed
já o acidente pelo menos uma década até
que os tornam lógico da insignificância
para mim e acredito que é importante
para mim que eu possa replicar ao longo
do tempo
para muitos de nós que eventualmente
todos e temos exercício não tem sentido
não é valorizado não tem significância e
enquanto que isto o tempo que leva a ter
significância para que eu possa
realmente dizer assim eu tenho rotina na
área
isto em minha vida a vários termos nós
somos muito bons rotular as pessoas
nomeadamente quem faz muito exigente
físico
hoje em dia e eventualmente chamado o
vigoréxico alguém tiver uma resposta
para mim quem tomava em todos os dias
como é que chama não é por necessidade
por não não
ou é publicidade está terminando aqui
acrescenta realmente nos dias de hoje
algo então toda a agenda hoje em dia
como esse da base que precisa do wifi da
bateria mas vocês estão bem com muita
vontade na casa do avaí mas foi em vão
ligar o portátil ou eventualmente alguma
coisa correndo antes de fazer pode
esperar porque realmente é importante
tem
significância para nós
como em tudo que nós fazemos temos que
ter paciência paciência paciência e
quando dizia assim o exercício físico é
sofrimento dói custa pois o humor também
nós amamos é mais simples manter uma
relação amorosa mantermos ligados nos
outros anos aqui até o ginásio durante
meia hora fazer morrido afogado na
bicicleta hoje às boxes e mig có tipo de
atividade física exercício físico
quando as coisas começam a ter algum
sentido tem alguma significância
eventualmente nós quando começamos em
conseguir mudar aquilo que é o paradigma
da educação pretendem uma aliança que
nós vamos deixar nossos filhos
as coisas vão começar a mudar porque
deixamos de olhar para o exercício da
atividade física como desporto apenas
mas tem outra mais valia para nós
emocionalmente psicologicamente
fisicamente e para todos nós como uma
comunidade que vem à cabeça
será será que acabou o nosso esforço que
muita gente tinha uma esperança nos
mantém andar dia após dia alguém tenha
resposta à minha pergunta então porque
quando nós não conseguimos ter
eventualmente é pressão do sucesso em
terminadas áreas como o exercício físico
rapidamente deixamos de fazer
coxim - temos que dar a volta a esta
questão
conscientemente nós temos que nos
obrigará a fumar e padrões fumar rotinas
para que as coisas continuem a fazer
sentido para nós
não tanto como vocês vêem que passa por
sessões vocês olham vem ou não eu vejo
uma próxima oportunidade e acredito
muito nisso
quando isso não é eventualmente uma
próxima oportunidade para que nossos fãs
daquela forma se eu não me identificar
com alguma forma de me exercitar
de alguma forma de poder alterar a minha
vida do uma oportunidade uma ou outra
forma de tentar aceitar com
tranquilidade que esta questão de
alterar padrões de vida tinas de vida é
realmente desafiantes tem um significado
diferente para todos nós
eventualmente vai contra aquilo que é a
nossa natureza
eu gostava de partilhar com isso com
você que é importante eu sou preguiçoso
quantas vezes é que vocês disseram esta
palavra é normal e natural
aceitei com naturalidade nos arranjar é
algo que faça sentido queremos contra
esta naturalidade
deixe que esta reflexão para vocês deixe
se que esta pequena partilha seria 15
minutos já passámos muito pouco tempo a
partilhar aquilo que é uma das minhas
paixões que eventualmente ajudar vos eu
gostava que vocês olharem para trás em
duas situações
havendo alguma coisa bonita pra ver nós
homens são especialistas nisso em olhar
e ver o olhar e búlgara aprendizagens e
pegar naquilo que foi passado com os
rails os insucessos não como forma
castradora 65 uma forma potenciadora
libertadora que se tiver algum
constrangimento passado e
somente vou focar nisso e transformar
isso em conhecimento para mim para nós
continuamos traçar um plano de ação
contudo nós vimos tudo o início tem um
processo eventualmente tem uma chegada
o fim pode não ser obrigado por vocês
teria ficado